je n'ai pas vraiment besoin de regarder les
chiffres je regarde juste les admissions nous le
voyons tous
le médecin est
je pense que même la plupart d'entre nous le faisons même
dans le cadre de notre routine matinale,
nous voulons savoir combien de lits nous  avoir
combien de personnes pouvons-nous admettre euh quel
type de lits pouvons-nous émettre combien de
patients cachés pouvons-nous prendre combien de
patients non couverts pouvons-nous prendre
dans les hôpitaux de montagne
notre nombre d'hôpitaux augmentera encore,
ce qui signifie que les soins aux albertains avec d'
autres problèmes en
plus  kovid sera touché
contact nous devons nous assurer que
tous ceux qui sont gravement malades dans cette
province reçoivent les soins dont ils ont besoin
c'est notre engagement en tant que
capitale gouvernementale deja transporte
si vous fermez une unité pendant une
épidémie, vous ne pouvez plus l'
admettre  unité
donc même si cette unité avait plusieurs
lits ouverts, ils ne sont plus
edmonton